We’re always staring up into space, trying
to figure out what we’re seeing.
We like to think we know what’s going on,
but what if we’ve been seeing it wrong this
WHOLE TIME.
Ok, a little context here.
Almost all normal galaxies have a supermassive
black hole at the center, including ours.
(That’s not freaky at all.)
BUT we can’t actually see the black holes
themselves--they’re so dense and their gravitational
field is so strong that nothing can escape
them, not even light.
So we observe them instead by seeing how the
matter around them behaves.
All of the ‘stuff’ in these galaxies is
verrrrry slowly falling in toward the black
hole, causing the galaxy to spiral and form
into a disk shape.
Some of these galaxies are special: the supermassive
black hole is consuming more than the normal
amount of the galaxy around it, and faster--it’s
greedy.
These are called active galactic nuclei, or
AGN for short.
As the matter in the galaxy gets closer to
the black hole, it heats up and produces all
kinds of radiation: we’ve got radio, we’ve
got infrared, X-ray, gamma ray--it’s a big
party.
This is called an accretion disk, and even
though we can’t ‘see’ the black hole
itself, the accretion disk around it is one
of the things we can observe when we’re
looking at AGN.
Accretion discs are one of a few characteristics
that form our standard model for what AGN
might look like.
Other typical features include gigantic jets
that eject stuff, and a torus (which is a
big donut of galactic material).
Depending on the circumstances though, we
may not see all the features we’re expecting,
and different AGN appear to have different
properties.
We’ve currently classified tens of different
kinds, based on observations of things like
brightness, size, jets, lack of jets and type
of radiation emitted.
They’re divided into radio-quiet and radio-loud
nuclei, and each of these types contains categories
of their own, like Seyfert galaxies, quasars,
and blazars, and each of these categories
has their own subdivisions as well.
But there’s a theory that posits something
a little radical, called AGN unification theory.
First proposed back in 1993, it claims that
essentially, all AGN are the same, but they
just LOOK different to us based on their orientation
in space.
I mean we’re limited, right?
We can’t exactly go out and fly around them
to see them in 360--we only have our perspective
from here from Earth.
However, supercomputers may be able to help
us figure this out.
With simulations, we can model AGN, allowing
us to twist and turn them, seeing what they
look like and what signals they gives off
from different angles.
Buuuut these models aren’t the perfect answer
to figuring out if AGN unification theory
is right.
We probably don’t even have all the necessary
data to make the most accurate models of galactic
behavior.
As we continue to get better at detecting
the signals coming from them, building more
powerful telescopes and asking even better
questions, hopefully we’ll get there soon.
It’s kind of awesome and mind blowing to
think about this.
Because the many different kinds of AGN have
been meticulously observed and grouped by
attribute, it can be easy as a non-astrophysicist
to say--”yep.
There they are, all the different kinds of
active galactic nuclei, aren’t we good at
looking at and labeling things”.
But then something like the AGN unification
theory comes along and suggests that this
may all be irrelevant because we haven’t
taken into account something as seemingly
simple as perspective...and it really makes
you feel like there’s so much more to be
discovered.
And our understanding of our universe is so
much more malleable than we may think.
Science isn’t a set of hard and fast rules,
it’s changing all the time.
And that might be my favorite part.
Make sure to subscribe down below to be the
first to know if AGN unification theory turns
out to be right, and check out this video
here on what happens when galaxies collide.
Also, quasars are AGN whose cores are so bright
that they outshine all the stars in their
galaxy.
And quasar stands for quasi-stellar radio
sources.
I always wondered how they came up with names
like that.
I’m Maren, thanks for watching Seeker.